she's here isn't she
hi ron
it's really good to see you ron
you've aged horribly
are you
the son of a [ __ ] that didn't tell you
oh my god what is your problem nothing's
changed has it he set the bed on fire
i did okay is that what you wanted we're
fine we're fine please
take it outside
oh god
oh yes baby you've done it
ron doesn't want to break up with me
what ron wants to do
is leave here right now
go to the sleaziest motel in town
and wrap himself around me like a coiled
snake
no he doesn't i'm pretty sure he does
hello tammy
oh
hello ron
i didn't see you come in
i was just checking myself for scoliosis
and straight as an arrow just like
somebody else i know
jerky
call off the dogs you and i both know
that in my entire adult life i have
never checked a book out of the library
oh my god she's amazing
oh
i admit there was a time when that sort
of behavior would have driven me wild
but i am in a healthy relationship now
tam a relationship with whom a lovely
intelligent self-possessed pediatric
surgeon named wendy sounds like a real
[ __ ]
[Music]
it's been like this for hours
oh
congratulate us
ron's got one just like it on his penis
oh yeah
what the hell happened to you
well
[Music]
[Music]
all right one more
what's in here huh
a new library card read the name tammy
swanson swanson
well you're about ready to go my love
wait wait run
stop tom jerry what the hell
don't do it she doesn't love you what
you don't know what you're talking about
what are you doing here yes i do okay
when i asked her to be my date she
cackled for a full minute and said and i
quote
anything to make ron miserable
it's not real man she's just messing
with you he's lying ron stay out of this
glenn it's tom and i'm not lying i'm not
gonna let you destroy ron you're just
gonna have to ow
ow
oh he's attacking me ron kill him
[Laughter]
yeah do your worst glenn
you're gonna have to do better than that
oh
why are you hitting yourself stop
hitting yourself tammy that's enough
hey baby
you almost had me
again
but seeing you pick on this pathetic
defenseless little man hey reminded me
what kind of a monster you are you're a
joke you're not even a man anymore oh
and by the way last night i faked four
out of the seven
so did i
let's go son
she's
here who's here
my ex-wife tammy too
i can smell the sulphur coming off her
cloven hooves good nose ron tammy
swanson is here she'll be my next
witness
tammy too is your killer witness please
you're gonna have to do better actually
she is a terrifying sociopath who could
say or do anything
a pretty good killer witness this could
end up being the best night in ron
swanson's life i am so so happy for him
hello you gorgeous
wow look at this room
so much wood ready to be worked
me
hey ron
what a coincidence
gosh i never dreamed you'd be here tammy
this is diane
diane this is a piece of human garbage
named tammy who is also my ex-wife oh my
gosh what a coinky-dinky look we're
sitting at the same table tammy this
table is reserved a guy traded me his
seat for a peek and a squeeze that's my
boob and my butt respectively remember
that ron
this award is the only one i'd ever give
a damn about
i made my first chair when i was five
but the quality of the wood was wanting
so when i turned nine i used my factory
wages to purchase some beautiful local
walnut
uh thank
you for this
uh this all good
night good
uh
there it is
[Applause]
well hello there big gross leslie
where's one it's too late tammy ron's
gone you'll never get him back want to
bet that relationship is weak all i have
to do is find ron within the next few
hours and he's toast
a few hours you say
leslie stop this car where are we going
don't know
you're gonna regret this
giving this a lot of thought
we should break up
what's the matter little boy did the bad
people get to you they just made me
realize how unhealthy this is
literally all the steak and whiskey i
have to wear a diaper that's cause
you're my little baby we drilled you on
this jam
baby talk what do you do
i'm not a baby i'm a big boy
yeah okay well that wasn't terrible
don't listen to leslie she's trying to
manipulate you all she cares about is
herself and i can prove it how's this
leslie
you leave us alone and we
swing the vote to you help you get your
park
no nice try stay strong jeremy
it's over tammy tell you what it's been
long enough
what do you say we
consummate our relationship
tonight
huh
let's
do it
and the last card is played what are you
doing shh this is a library you see
what's happening here ron i need that
crotch blinder no you don't just end it
look at my boobs no look downstairs no
there's a prize inside for you it's over
tammy what
to hell with you woman goodbye
how dare you are you kidding me you'll
be back they all come back well done
jeremy
turns out the crotch blinder was inside
you all along
you